liberticide anticonstitutionnel
dictatorial les opposants au passé ni
tard et à la vaccination obligatoire ne
mâchent pas leurs mots pour qualifier lé
dernier outil de lutte contre le kobe 19
mises en place par le gouvernement a
déjà instauré dans les lieux dits de
culture et loisirs comme les musées
cinémas parc d'attractions rassemblant
plus de 50 personnes ne pas sanitaire
pourrait être étendue aux cafés
restaurants centres commerciaux ainsi qu
aux avions trains cars pour les longs
trajets ou encore aux établissements
médicaux face caméra tenue décontractée
emmanuel macron elle défend bec et
ongles le pass sanitaires à dans une
vidéo publiée sur les réseaux sociaux
est enregistrée depuis son lieu de
vacances le fort de brégançon
si nous n'avions pas le planétaire
aujourd'hui on serait obligé de refermer
c'est à dire de faire porter la
contrainte sur tout le monde avec le
pass à lithaire on l'a fait porter
uniquement sur celles et ceux qui ne se
sont pas encore fait vacciner et en leur
demandant de se crisper pour protéger
les autres
la contrainte ou la punition est plutôt
que contraindre pourquoi ne pas
convaincre
parmi les anti-pacs sanitaires ils sont
nombreux à s'inquiéter du manque de
recul sur le vaccin ou encore à craindre
les effets à long terme quand d'autres
dont plusieurs vacciner à craignent de
voir une france à deux vitesses avec des
gens qui ont des droits et d'autres qui
en ont perdu en gros les bons et les
méchants une situation explosive en vous
l'aurez compris avec des manifestations
qui se multiplient aux quatre coins de
la france dans la tente d'une lueur
d'espoir et elle pourrait venir du
conseil constitutionnel qui va examiner
le projet de loi de l'extension du passé
ni terre
outre le recours déposé par de nombreux
députés 1 2
rédigé par un collectif d'avocats
appelle des sages a annulé ou retoqué ce
projet qualifié d' inconstitutionnelle
et portant atteinte je cite aux libertés
individuelles
plus de cinquante mille personnes ont
signé ce recours
on peut s'attendre à une guerre
judiciaire s'il n'est pas pris en compte
et que la loi et valider ou pas assez
retoqué les vaccins n'ont pas reçu
d'autorisation définitif de mise sur le
marché
cela pose donc un vrai problème
juridique de soumettre les salariés à
l'acceptation de ces produits
pharmaceutiques
parce que oui le projet de loi prévoit
également pour les salariés des
entreprises accueillant du public que le
pass sanitaires leur soit obligatoire
autrement il pourrait être suspendu sans
salaire jusqu'à éventuellement perdre
leur emploi
je crois qu'il faut être clair cela ne
veut pas dire qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de licenciements
cela veut dire qu'il est moins encadré
peut-être qu'il pourra intervenir plus
tôt on est dans le droit commun du droit
du travail et il y à plus grave dans le
texte
le pack sanitaire compte aussi être
étendue aux établissements médicaux sauf
urgence une mesure qui suscite sans
surprise l'inquiétude de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé à commencer par
l'ordre national des médecins
l'ordre des médecins rappelle que la
mission du service public assumées par
tous les soignants est de garantir
l'accès aux soins pour tous l'ordre des
médecins attend la réponse du conseil
constitutionnel chargé du fait de sa
saisine de garantir l'égal accès aux
soins de tous les citoyens de notre pays
et alors que ce projet de loi n'est pas
censé être appliquée avant le 9 août
avec ou sans feu vert du conseil
constitutionnel
un ambulancier explique qu'une clinique
a refusé la prise en charge d'une
patiente pour non présentation de pas
sanitaires son témoignage a fait le tour
des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui nous avons déposé une
passion dans une clinique privée pour
effectuer un examen du coeur petit
examen qui lui était refusé pour seul
l'unique motif que cette dame n'a pas pu
présenter de passani terre donc
aujourd'hui on s'assoit sur le serment
d'hippocrate
on s'associe sur la liberté d'accès aux
sons
c'est inadmissible c'est lamentable
bienvenue en france le conseil
constitutionnel va-t-il mettre le holà
ou au contraire conforté comme il l'a
déjà fait à plusieurs reprises les
décisions du gouvernement
réponse attendue comme le messie ce
jeudi